Er fuhr hier,
darum konnte ihn gar niemand sehen.
Er hat ihn geschleift
und vor das Auto gelegt.
Und fuhr einfach hin und her,
um ihn zu töten.
Sie sind auf mich gesprungen und
fragten mich, wo die Leiche sei.
Ich war natürlich
ziemlich überrascht.
Ich meinte ...
Ich wusste gar nicht,
wovon die Rede ist.
Der Tag von Andrea Rodrigues beginnt
um 6 Uhr mit Kaffee und Zigarette.
Ein tägliches Ritual
für die 35-jährige Mutter aus Rafz
im Kanton Zürich.
Seit 2016 ist sie alleinerziehend.
Soll ich noch mit ihr rausgehen?
Ja, du kannst noch kurz mit ihr
spazierengehen, wenn du möchtest.
Das ist anspruchsvoll, jeden Morgen
für drei Kinder zu sorgen.
Ähm, ja also ...
* Bellen *
Ich habe mich schon daran gewöhnt.
Es war ja vorher nicht anders
und jetzt ist es auch nicht anders.
Es ist irgendwie mein Alltag.
Was nimmst du?
Möchtest du ein Glas Saft?
Die drei Mädchen
sind sechs, acht und zwölf Jahre alt
und haben keinen Vater mehr.
Willst du eine grosse
oder eine kleine?
Eine kleine. Ist die gut?
Mit 20 heiratete die Slowakin Andrea
Manisova ihre erste grosse Liebe:
Luiz Rodrigues.
Was in der Schweiz romantisch begann,
endet in einer Katastrophe:
Luiz Rodrigues bringt 2016
in Rafz einen Rentner um.
Das Opfer ist Gino Bornhauser.
In diesen Polizeiakten
sind die letzten Minuten
seines Lebens dokumentiert.
Für seine Frau Petra
eine grosse Last.
Sie muss damit leben, dass ihr Mann,
von dem sie getrennt lebte,
auf einem Parkplatz in Rafz
niedergeschlagen
und seine Leiche
bis heute nicht gefunden wurde.
Ich glaube,
das wird gar nie richtig aufgeklärt.
Ich muss mich einfach damit abfinden
und fertig.
Es gibt nichts anderes.
Er ist einfach tot.
Ja.
Die Tat geschieht
an einem Freitag im April 2016.
Gino Bornhauser
beobachtet von einer Bank aus
eine ihm fremde
Familie auf dem Spielplatz.
Es ist die Familie
von Luiz Rodrigues.
Als dieser zum Spass
seine Tochter in die Luft wirft,
ruft ihm Gino Bornhauser zu, ob er
eine gute Lebensversicherung habe.
Rodrigues fühlt sich provoziert,
geht zum Rentner, sie streiten sich.
Kurz darauf setzt sich
Gino Bornhauser in sein Auto
und will wegfahren.
Er stoppt vor Luiz Rodrigues,
der gerade den Parkplatz überquert.
Wieder kommt es zum Streit.
Andrea Rodrigues spielt noch
mit den Kindern auf dem Spielplatz.
Wir waren ja auch ziemlich weit weg,
so abgeschieden.
Wir haben nichts mitbekommen.
Der Streit auf den Parkplatz
eskaliert.
Luiz Rodrigues schlägt
Gino Bornhauser brutal zusammen.
Dann hievt er
den bewusstlosen Rentner ins Auto.
Mehrere Zeugen sehen die Tat,
doch niemand alarmiert die Polizei.
Petra Bornhauser hat Bilder
des Angriffs auf ihren Mann,
weil eine Anwohnerin
die Tat mit ihrem Handy filmte.
Ja, das sind die Fotos,
die sie vom Video machten.
Hier liegt offensichtlich mein Mann.
Er schlägt ihn hier zusammen.
Sehen Sie hier!
Er zeigte das quasi:
Wenn ihr nicht verschwindet,
geht es euch gleich wie dem hier.
Hier ist auch ein Zeuge.
Aber da war mein Mann wahrscheinlich
bewusstlos.
Nachher ist er losgefahren.
An einem Waldrand lädt Luiz Rodrigues
den bewusstlosen Rentner
aus dem Auto
und überfährt ihn mehrmals.
Er will sicher sein,
dass er tot ist.
Die Leiche deponiert er danach
an einem unbekannten Ort im Wald
und fährt weg.
Zwei Tage später findet
die Polizei ein ausgebranntes Auto
im Grenzgebiet zu Deutschland.
Es gehört Gino Bornhauser,
von dem jede Spur fehlt.
Am nächsten Tag
kam die Vermisstmeldung.
Ich habe alles
aus den Medien erfahren.
Die Polizei war sehr zurückhaltend.
Erst nach ca. fünf Tagen
kamen sie zu mir.
Sie haben die Vermutung geäussert,
dass ein Gewaltverbrechen
passiert sein könnte.
(Nachrichtensprecher)
Nach dem Verschwinden eines Mannes
im Zürcher Unterland
geht die Polizei jetzt
von einem Verbrechen aus.
Sie fand das Auto des Vermissten
total ausgebrannt.
Der Fall Bornhauser
macht schweizweit Schlagzeilen,
bald wird spekuliert, ob es sich um
einen Mordfall ohne Leiche handelt.
Die Polizei führt mehrere
grossflächige Suchaktionen durch,
der Aufwand
beträgt über 7'200 Mannstunden.
Doch die Leiche
findet die Polizei nicht,
nur Kleider von Gino Bornhauser -
mit Blutspuren, verstreut an
verschiedenen Orten im Wald um Rafz.
Wieso hat er ihn ausgezogen?
Das verstehe ich echt nicht.
Dass so ein Typ
so etwas machen kann.
Oder gemacht hat.
Ich verstehe es einfach nicht.
Er hätte ja sein Leben
noch vor sich gehabt,
mit seinen Kindern.
Luiz Rodrigues:
Als er neun Jahre alt ist,
holt ihn seine Mutter aus Brasilien
in die Schweiz.
Sie arbeitet in einer Bar,
hat kaum Zeit für ihn.
Er beginnt mehrere Lehren,
schliesst aber keine ab.
Mit 20 lernt er dann
seine spätere Frau Andrea kennen.
Als ich ihn kennengelernt habe,
war er fröhlich
und unternehmungslustig.
Er hatte viele Ideen, viel Elan
und viele Freunde.
Ja, ich war ...
Ich war ein Gegensatz von ihm,
die stille Maus.
Das hat mich eben so
an ihm angezogen.
So haben wir uns auch kennengelernt.
Und, ja ...
Nach und nach
ist das alles verschwunden.
Er verbietet seiner Frau und
den Kindern nach draussen zu gehen.
Überall sieht er Gefahren für sie.
Das sind alte Bilder.
Überall ist sein Körper drauf.
Sein Körper war ihm sehr wichtig.
Er leidet an einer paranoiden
Persönlichkeitsstörung
und wird zum IV-Bezüger.
Seine Wut lässt er an seiner Frau
aus, es kommt zu häuslicher Gewalt.
Ich habe ihm
auch ein Ultimatum gestellt:
Wenn sich nichts ändert,
dann würde ich hier weggehen.
Ich war dadurch
depressiv und lustlos.
Ich hatte ...
... keine Kraft mehr,
irgendetwas zu tun.
Das hat mich einfach kaputt gemacht.
Fünf Wochen nach der Tat
verhaftet die Polizei
Luiz und Andrea Rodrigues.
Den entscheidenden Hinweis geben
die Daten von diesem Bancomaten:
Andrea Rodrigues
wurde von Luiz beauftragt,
mit Gino Bornhausers
Bankkarte Geld abzuheben.
Doch der PIN-Code ist falsch.
Andrea Rodrigues bezieht
danach mit ihrer eigenen Karte Geld.
Der Bancomat registriert alles
und führt die Polizei
zu Luiz Rodrigues.
In Untersuchungshaft
gesteht der Brasilianer,
dass er Gino Bornhauser
umgebracht hat und erklärt,
dass seine Frau
nichts mit dem Fall zu tun habe.
Andrea Rodrigues wird
nach zwei Tagen U-Haft entlassen.
Als Luiz ein weiteres Mal
von der Polizei befragt wird,
kann Petra Bornhauser zuhören.
Sie sieht erstmals den
mutmasslichen Mörder ihres Mannes.
Dann haben wir gehört, wie sie
den Täter, Herrn Rodrigues,
gebracht haben,
mit Fussfesseln und Handschellen.
Er hatte eine Lederjacke an.
Er war eigentlich eine angenehme,
saubere Erscheinung.
Das hat mir sehr weh getan.
Dass ein Mensch in Ketten
hereingeführt wird.
Er war also quasi
ein Schwerverbrecher.
Ich sehe immer beide Seiten.
Auch da habe ich
beide Seiten gesehen.
Einerseits
hat mir der Typ leid getan,
andererseits musste ich mir sagen,
dass er etwas sehr, sehr Schlimmes
getan hat.
Dann wurde er verhört.
Wir sassen hinten.
Ich glaube, von dieser Stunde
habe ich 49 Min. nur geheult.
Ich musste mich immer wieder fassen.
Weil, es ist heute noch so:
Ich kann nicht verstehen,
dass man so etwas macht.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie ich das beschreiben soll.
Es war einfach immer noch
mein Ehemann und ... ähm ...
Ich ... ähm ...
... war ja ...
Wir haben uns ja einmal gesagt:
In guten und in schlechten Zeiten.
Im Gefängnis
fragen Staatsanwaltshaft und Polizei
den Brasilianer immer wieder,
wo er die Leiche deponiert habe.
Luiz Rodrigues
macht dann diese Zeichnungen.
Sie sollen den Ort zeigen,
wo er Gino Bornhauser abgelegt hat.
Auch in den Befragungen versucht er,
den Ort zu beschreiben,
wie diese Protokolle zeigen.
Er zeichnet einen Zaun.
Dort habe er die Leiche
bei einem Baumstumpf abgelegt.
Er habe Gino Bornhauser
nicht vergraben.
An diesen Zeichnungen und Aussagen
sind jedoch Zweifel angebracht,
denn Luiz Rodrigues sagte selber,
dass er während der Fahrt
mit der Leiche einen Filmriss hatte
und sich
nicht orientieren konnte.
Die Leiche bleibt verschwunden.
2017 wird Luiz Rodrigues
wegen Mordes angeklagt,
der Prozess in Bülach
soll im Dezember 2017 stattfinden.
Doch so weit kommt es nicht.
Zweieinhalb Monate
vor dem Prozess
essen Luiz Rodrigues
und sein Zellennachbar
abends im Zürcher Flughafengefängnis
Birchermüesli.
Danach spielen sie Uno und Schach.
Laut dem Zellennachbarn schreibt
Luiz Rodrigues dann einen Brief.
Er habe gesagt,
dieser sei für seine Frau,
wie dieses Einvernahmeprotokoll
der Polizei zeigt.
Am nächsten Morgen
liegt der 36-jährige Brasilianer
tot in seinem Bett.
Laut dem
rechtsmedizinischen Gutachten
starb Luiz Rodrigues
an einer Morphinvergiftung.
Von wem er das Medikament erhielt,
konnte die Polizei
nicht herausfinden,
als Todesart
kommen Unfall und Suizid in Frage.
Mitarbeiter
des Forensischen Instituts Zürich
finden im WC und im Abfall
leere Medikamentenkapseln,
jedoch keinen Abschiedsbrief.
Also ich kann ...
... immer noch nicht fassen
und begreifen.
Ich habe ...
Ich habe gefragt,
ob er vielleicht einen
Abschiedsbrief hinterlassen hat
oder sonst etwas.
Angeblich haben sie nichts gefunden.
Das ist die Asche von ihm.
Sie wollten die Urne zukleben,
aber ich wollte das nicht.
Er braucht einfach seine Freiheit.
Das, was er wollte ...,
... natürlich seine Zigaretten.
Ohne sie konnte er nicht leben.
Das ist wie ein Ersatz für mich.
Wenn mein Tag schwierig ist, oder
ich mich schlecht fühle, einsam.
Dann komme ich hierher und ja ...
... spreche, rede, weine.
Es ist ... ähm ...
... als wäre er immer noch da.
Ich hoffe,
du hast jetzt deinen Frieden.
Vielleicht auch nicht, wenn ich ihn
jeden Tag vollquatsche.
Gleich hier vorne.
Petra Bornhauser wird sich wohl nie
von ihrem Mann verabschieden können,
seine Leiche liegt vermutlich
irgendwo in einem Wald.
Sie besucht zum zweiten Mal den Ort,
an dem ihr Mann überfahren
und getötet wurde.
Hier hat es einen Plastiksack.
Das ist doch ein Plastiksack.
Wieso liegt hier ein Plastiksack?
Ist das ein Kehrichtsack?
Wenn er ihn vielleicht
hier vergraben hat?
Hier haben sie vermutlich
alles abgesucht.
Das ist jetzt etwas unheimlich.
* Sie seufzt. *
Warum ist es für Sie wichtig,
an diesen Ort zu kommen?
Vielleicht finden wir
einmal den Ort,
an dem er ihn wirklich abgelegt hat.
Vielleicht zeigt es uns etwas auf.
Oder, dass auch die Leute
ein wenig aufmerksam sind,
wenn sie in den Wäldern sind,
sehen sie vielleicht etwas.
Das sollten sie der Polizei melden.
Damit wir ihn trotzdem einmal ...
ja ...
... zu Grabe tragen können.
Das wäre mein Wunsch.
* Dumpfe, traurige Klänge *
Heute ist ein spezieller Tag
für Andrea Rodrigues.
Es ist
ein komisches Gefühl im Magen.
Ich war seit dem Tag nie mehr hier.
Das ist seither das erste Mal,
dass wir hier spielen gehen.
Auf diesem Parkplatz schlug
ihr Mann Gino Bornhauser nieder.
Es ist komisch, hier zu sein.
Andrea Rodrigues
arbeitet heute wieder.
Als Luiz noch zu Hause war,
durfte sie das nicht.
Das Leben hat sich auch
für die Kinder verändert.
Sie können mehr als vorher.
Das ist das,
was die Kinder brauchen:
draussen sein und Freunde treffen.
Eben Kinder sein.
Die Kinder wissen, dass ihr Vater
einen Menschen umgebracht hat
und dann
im Gefängnis gestorben ist.
Mehr wissen sie nicht.
Diesen Herbst kommt es dann
zu einem ganz besonderen Treffen
zwischen Andrea Rodrigues
und Petra Bornhauser.
Denn während den Dreharbeiten
kam die Idee auf,
dass sich die zwei Witwen
kennenlernen könnten.
Guten Morgen!
- Guten Morgen!
Wie geht's?
- (Seufzend) Ja.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Es ist eine traurige Sache.
Für Petra Bornhauser ist dieses
Treffen ein lang gehegter Wunsch -
sie will wissen,
ob Luiz Rodrigues die Tat bereute.
Hat es ihm leid getan?
Was denken Sie?
Er hat das ganz bestimmt bereut.
Er hat es mir ja ...
... auch oft geschrieben,
dass er gar nicht nachgedacht hat,
was er da tat.
Er hat es schon bereut, aber er
konnte es nicht rückgängig machen.
Das ist so.
- Man kann nichts ändern.
Ja, man kann gar nichts ändern.
Ich denke,
beide haben irgendwelche Schuld.
Ich denke das, weil ... ja ...
Ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen,
was mein Mann gesagt hat,
dass ihr Mann so ...
... böse wurde.
Ja, das weiss ich auch nicht,
was da geschehen ist.
Ich denke, ohne Grund
wäre es ja nicht passiert.
Das ist schon so.
Er war ja stur und dickköpfig.
Er meinte, er müsse sich beweisen.
Ich denke, das war mein Mann auch.
Stur. Er konnte nicht aufhören.
Aber sie trifft ja keine Schuld
in diesem Sinne.
Das sagen mir viele,
aber ich ... ähm ...
... habe so grosse Schuldgefühle
in mir.
Wenn er verärgert war ...
Etwas hat ihn ja verärgert.
Er hat seine Wut
immer zu Hause an mir ausgelassen.
Ich sagte zu ihm:
"Wenn dich jemand verärgert,
dann lass es an dem aus
und nicht an mir."
Ja, das ist dann ...
Darum gebe ich mir dafür die Schuld,
weil ich das gesagt habe.
Tja, ich denke,
wir müssen darüber hinwegkommen
und versuchen,
unser Leben weiterzuführen.
Ich wünsche für Sie, dass Sie
keine Schuldgefühle mehr haben,
also v.a. gegenüber mir.
Wie mit einem Verbrechen umgehen?
Diese zwei Frauen sind dabei,
einen Weg zu finden.
Doch ganz damit abschliessen
werden sie wohl nie können.